welcome to air kim usually planes are
like dark with lighter leather mine i
had custom all light wood kim kardashian
gives a tour of her ultra luxe private
plane and the skims founder has a
swooning over her one of a kind home in
the sky i never dreamed i would own a
plane it's just i wanted it to feel like
an extension of me and an extension of
my home it's all in the details for kim
who shares an inside look at her private
jet on hulu's the kardashians and let's
just put it this way it's luxurious af i
had a bathroom put in the front a
bathroom in the back
every seat has its own phone charger no
surprise here the aircraft fits kim's
signature neutral yet glam aesthetic the
best most exciting part of the plane is
it's all cashmere
your ceilings pillows headrests i feel
like i'm doing an mtv cribs for planes
like oh what a dream we feel like we're
on cloud nine and in first class with
him it's so crazy
the reason for the plane tour well it's
kim's first flight since she decided to
buy and design her own jet the reality
star is joined by some pals as she jets
off to the dominican republic for her
sports illustrated shoot and the beauty
mogul already has some ground rules for
her passengers don't touch a thing
is so nice don't breathe don't touch a
thing
just kidding
oh i'm gonna do no shoes on the plane
and get custom skim slippers leave it to
the skim's founder to always have her
next business move in mind so wouldn't
it be so cute with if i made custom
skins in this color like you're gonna do
it pajamas
socks and blankets and slippers
and then i'm like
instead of that like clay lacy runner it
should say like air kim or wait kim air
no what's michael jordan's air
i think kim air and guys you've probably
noticed by now kim air isn't your
ordinary flying experience so naturally
when kim's bow pete davidson facetimes
her she had to give him a peek inside we
have two
beds in the back but this can all come
out as one king bed
it's really cute it's like so perfect
it's so cool it's such a moment right
nice
bye
but little did kim know pete had a
little something up his sleeve we have a
special surprise so this comes from me
for the plate oh my god
shut up these are my favorites thanks
pete
so yeah they don't actually show us what
the surprise was i'm thinking it could
be kim's favorite flowers or candy but
that smile says it all i don't know how
you're gonna top that
it seems kim's been smiling a lot lately
thanks to pete whom she started dating
in october and when she spoke to e.t
last month she told us why the comedian
has her feeling so smitten what's your
favorite thing about him um
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
[Music]
you